josh rogers we'll start with him his
third start this season sixth of his
career a total of eight games and three
starts with baltimore back in 2018
and
2019.
and for miguel rojas on this roberto
clemente day wearing number 21 as he is
for a second consecutive season the
marlins nominee for the roberto clemente
award
got him looking rojas thought he had
walked
after reaching extending and following
off away pitches he took the one in
one two
swing
and a miss
two k's to start the day he over matches
the left-hander there
he will strike out the side
nine pitches to get rojas
diaz and de la cruz disposed up quickly
you see what trevor can do and this is
23rd start this season
coming off kind of a mixed bag loss
against the atlanta braves there was a
string in there where he was perfect he
retired 11 in a row but then the braves
bats started to come to life and he
ended up giving up a season high four
earned runs
3-2
is a called strike three
i'll tell you what these rogers are okay
today that's four outs in the game and
all strikeouts
and this is third start since coming
back escobar smelling a hit that ball
took a left turn
he was hustling to the bag had he seen
it he might have turned and thought
about second but his son diaz just
watches that ball made a turn and got
away from him
yeah i hear that sound now watch this
ball kick left
oh you're going good when stuff like
that happens
right
you're living the good life
and he's going to go the other way with
it
josh doesn't do that a ton from the
right side but what a great swing and
the nets have two on two out for kibbutz
and that's a rocket but right to issan
diaz
escobar bell with base hits two stranded
3-2
he will take his first big league walk
he has one
sacrifice and a base on balls and that's
important
as lane thomas who hits lefty as well as
next
now to center brinson started in able to
recover a step back
rogers leaves a couple first quarters
and the line drive that's key boom right
there on the right side so a one pitch
out
and scoreless early our guys dealing
their guy pretty good too escobar soto
and bell straight ahead
how about a drive to right field and two
for two escobar infield hit pulled
you called it he's going right man
and he's gonna
get one to left field that's gabard
we'll check in at second oh my goodness
juan soto hit number 141
he's among the top ten
hit guys in the national league now
one ball two strikes escobar
a single is at second soto is single is
at first
and a swing and a miss there
so bell down on strikes
there it is a called strike three bottom
of the zone froze him on a fastball back
to back case
and two outs here in the third
bouncer up the middle miggy is there
makes the throw over to first
and after the
two singles to start rogers gets a
couple of k's and a ground ball to get
us to the fourth
jordy popped up to short first time
that's a rocket and diaz can't reach
that one extra basis for jordy mercer
that's gonna be his seventh extra base
hit of the year on double number six
so with two outs you need to hit from
lane thomas
how about this one nobody's catching it
and that was a rocket to put the nets on
top
18th rbi in 29 games as a national
nothing that almost got trevor rogers
[Applause]
well hit base hit
two more knocks ladies and gentlemen
here he comes here he comes on the
outside juan soto in the batty race he's
liking the clubhouse stretching i think
down the stretch he comes
and to center
back for it brinson battling that sudden
he lost it
and it bounces out for a double putting
runners on second and third
the sun is right behind home plate here
this time of the year
that's by one trying to double it triple
it or quadruple it
[Applause]
that will bring the tying run to the
plate the person of jesus sanchez
sanchez drives one out to left field
this one is gone into the bullpen
two run game tying home run for jesus
sanchez
that stayed up at 80 miles an hour
yeah we saw this in atlanta you know
staying through the baseball against the
lefty but really flexing the muscles
here
well he continues to come through with
the big swing for the marlins all right
runners on first and third nobody out
for one soto
soto hits it hard to left
caught by de la cruz it's gonna put the
nets on top
as thomas speeds over
1-1
and jazz gives one a ride out towards
center field that is off the wall
sandy leone will stop at third jazz gets
into second base with a double
didn't miss a home run by all that much
sinker slider
ground ball off of thompson bell's got
it leon's coming home and miggy safe at
first we're tied
hey let's take another look rojas good
swing one hopper off thompson boy we've
seen enough of that in this series
this ball game is tied
bases loaded two outs
[Applause]
all the pressure on anthony bass
and he misses outside
can you believe that
five bases loaded walks in this series i
actually can
and now escobar already with a three-hit
day
escobar right field ball dropping it's
on the ground
adam scores zimmerman held it third by
bob henley the line's moving and the
nets lead by two nice
brian de la cruz two for seven a
strikeout and a walk thus far in the
series
there's a swing at a high fly ball this
thing is hammered deep to left field
forget about it
boy how quickly the marlins get one back
a lot of back and forth second half of
this game they try to buy a run
bellon hernandez who hit around kibum
and he launches one to right
c
u
later
facade of the second deck
and number 27
has the nats on top by two again
the tying runs aboard in the ninth
inning and here is miguel rojas
and miggy pokes one through a base head
one run will score they'll hold jazz and
it's six to five again infield in for
the nationals tying run 90 feet away
ground ball knocked down by escobar they
get the out at second but jazz comes in
to score
we are tied at six
they may not be done yet
pitch to jesus sanchez is cracked in the
air deep left field get up get up out of
here it's eight to six miami
the marlins have scored four runs in the
top of the ninth inning to go ahead in
this ball game
oh
hey zoo sanchez do it
it's his second two run home run of the
afternoon his 11th and 12th home runs of
this season what a day what a day
2-2 on the way
that one is popped up lewin diaz foul
ground makes the catch
it's a marlins win
you